hi my name is Julian I'm a googler based
in Brussels and I've been working for
many years with some of the largest
organizations in Europe to help them
deploy sensitive data sets and workloads
on Google Cloud
in this video I will show you how you
can use assured workloads to implement
supplementary data protection measures
that can help meet the requirements of
the European data protection authorities
as Europeans we know how important this
is to perform a risk assessment
surrounding your use of cloud services
and to implement appropriate risk
mitigation based on your findings
this is why Google cloud has made it
easy to implement controls using a short
workloads
in the next few minutes we'll walk
through step by step how to set up a new
Au assured workloads folder in the
Google Cloud console so that you can
enforce data residency Implement
Personnel access controls and manage
your organization encryption keys are
you ready
let's get started
[Music]
as we discussed in the first video
assured workloads is a tool that helps
you implement and enforce specific
controls so you can confidently run
sensitive workloads on Google clouds all
organizations need to do is to select
the regulatory framework they need to
comply with in our case the Au and
Google Cloud will automatically deploy
the necessary controls to help meet the
relevant requirements organizations in
the Au want to store and process data
locally to help prevent unauthorized
data transfers they also need protection
from unauthorized data access including
third-party data requests covered under
legislation like the US Cloud act
assured workloads for Au can support
these requirements allowing customers to
create and maintain workloads with data
residency at rest and in use in AU
Google Cloud regions
Personnel access and customer support
limited to Au persons located in the AU
and cryptographic control over data
access including external Key Management
key access justification and signed
access approval
but with a European Union data residency
custom ERS can specify any of the Google
Cloud regions in the EU where their data
will be stored and ensure that it will
remain there
a short workload implements a Google
Cloud platform organization policy that
restricts customer data to being stored
in a specific region
customers can choose from 10 current
cloud regions in Europe London Belgium
Netherlands Zurich Frankfurt Finland
Warsaw Milan Madrid Paris and more to
come second
there is personal data Access Control
these ensure that only Au Personnel in
an au location are allowed to provide
support to a customer
this control also restricts access to
customer data to individuals who meet
this requirement during the resolution
of a customer initiated support case
third there is cryptographic control
over data access
with key access justification
Cloud external key manager
and signed access approval key access
justification gives customers the
ability to deny Google administrators
access to their data for any reason
even in situations typically Exempted
from customer control such as outages or
response to third-party data requests
such as Do's under the authority of the
US Cloud act customers are provided a
clear reason why data is being decrypted
which they can use to decide whether to
permit decryption and thus allow access
to their data
what this means is that there is no way
for Google to decrypt customer data at
rest without a customer's approval which
you can withhold for any reason Cloud
external key manager allows you to use
encryption keys that are stored and
managed outside of Google Cloud's
infrastructure
and signed access approval adds a layer
of extra assurance that ensures explicit
customer content for any administrative
access to customer data or
configurations
let's take a closer look at how to get
started
first visit to Google Cloud console at
cloud.google.com console
before you can set up an assured
workloads environment you must select an
organization
then navigate to the compliance section
in the compliance section you will have
to create a new assured workloads folder
or use an existing Azure workloads
folder within your organization's Cloud
hierarchy
for each existing folder you can see its
name creation time compliance type data
region and labels
click create to create a new assured
workloads folder you will first need to
check that you meet the prerequisites
for folder creation this means having
one access transparency enabled for your
organization this provides you an audit
trail of support actions 2. a parent
folder registered using the provided
request for
three a premium subscription to assured
workloads this is required for assured
workloads for Au
4. private preview access this is
required if you want to use the Au
regions and support with sovereignty
controls compliance type
select the geographic area in which you
aim to meet data residency requirements
assured workloads offers control in the
au but also the US and Canada as of
today
let's pick a u and click next
offer two options Au regions and support
and Au regions and support with
sovereignty controls
Au regions and support sets controls for
data residency to Au regions and sets
controls for support Personnel to Au
persons located in the Au
Au regions and support with sovereignty
controls adds a layer of cryptographic
controls over data access activating
external key manager key access
justifications and signed access
approval
let's pick Au regions and support for
now
click next
by the AU region you would like to
restrict your workload tool select Au
which provides access to multiple Au
regions
click next
select the parent folder you registered
earlier as the place where your new
folder will live
this parent folder signals to resources
that a regulatory boundary is set and
requires all resources in that folder to
use the specific policies and controls
try to choose a folder that is not
registered you will get an error like
this
then give your assured workloads folder
a name
and click next
the last step is configuring your key
management project and keyring this will
create a separate Key Management project
within your assured workloads folder and
a keyring in which to place your keys
the key ring sets you up to utilize
customer managed encryption keys or
externally managed encryption keys
additionally if you want to keep your
encryption keys outside of Google's
infrastructure you will need to
configure external key management and
key access justification which you can
do from The Details page once you finish
creating this folder
click next
this brings you to the review section
where you can review compliance type
details folder name and location and
supported products
click create to create the assured
workloads folder
now you will see the new assured
workloads folder in your list
from this point forward any folder or
project created inside of this folder
will inherit the guardrails you
specified now that your folder is
created let's set up encryption keys
click on your new assured workloads
folder within the folder Details page
you will see the encryption section
which shows you information about the
separate Key Management project created
for you click on the project name to
open it
when entering a project inside of the
assured workloads regulatory boundary
customers are presented with a
regulatory intercept that warns them
about entering sensitive data in the
environment and locks their
acknowledgments and access to the
project navigate to the key management
section of the console click on the key
ring that was created for you then click
create key give your new key a name and
click create
once your key has been created click the
actions button on the right side and
select copy resource name this will be
important for later
now let's take a look at how you can
create a cloud resource within your
assured workloads folder using your new
encryption key
create a new project within the assured
workloads folder you created earlier
make sure to set the location
appropriately
once your project is created selected
and acknowledge the compliance agreement
navigate to the cloud storage section of
the console
you can now use the key you created
earlier to encrypt a cloud storage
bucket as you create it
give your bucket a bucket name you'll
notice that the data location options
are restricted to the regions within the
AU
select the default options for location
storage class and access control
then click data encryption
select customer managed encryption key
and then Enter key resource name
paste in the key resource name you
copied earlier and click save
click Grant to verify that the service
account has permission to encrypt and
decrypt with the selected key finally
click create and confirm to create your
brackets
congratulations you have now
successfully created a cloud resource
that follows the Au regions and Support
Compliance regime
assured workloads also restrict
customers to using specific products and
services blocking developers from
accidentally violating requirements set
by the organization administrator
so there you have it a walkthrough of
how you can get started with the short
workloads in the European Union to
easily deploy supplementary data
protection measures to workloads on
Google Cloud
if you want to learn more visit
cloud.google.com
assured hyphen workloads
and stay tuned for more episodes of our
short workloads and sovereignty updates
to learn how to build cloud workloads
with compliance in mind
thanks for watching
[Music]